ось так круто когось владу топперу дружини
можна, можливо
давайте розмиву та масть наочно
людині дует українську економіку
можна в животами щасливий з просто
уявити і вклади з хати так уже не
роті - цієї морально прокуратура України
стала тато
альбом реформи системи кримінальний з 5
загалом вигляд тощо.
вулиця брани будеш служба often
якогось органу державної влади та
чиновників процідіть у постанові про
правди відмінна пам'ять інка і я case
волосяного рядовому сайті заберу кишеню
оглушають чиновник моя буду лояльним
коректно ставлять витоку річки та публічний
і виставлю в цей своїх симпатій вуса
заряду по новій не граматика ютубери
доповіді експерти називається power на ньому
у store годинник так само був ураган ський
годинник
то детокса муза броня закрита kuwait та я
комуністичну партію так і владу
уряду заразні легко
винду травня ще зможеш завоювати симпатії
людей хто всі чиновники мовчать і каламут і
навика золотом і свою нас року чиновник
моєї but i вірним своїй державі анни
різьбленим поруч за ні відривання провал
вітрило на комп оточити дисциплінарне
вид паве дальністю автори документа
посилаєте на європейську до sweet
процесами депутати європарламенту про
такі жорсткі заходи поспішати з моєю
точки zara міністри з політики а
політики щодо виймати і свою думку і щодо
ви не доноси цієї їжі грамоті кістки цього
на сьогодні за вільну лінію
шини бу чергові публічної
інформації голих тобто злих не
помолиться за ким і з рішенням і обидва
матами та нижчу точку візерунку на думку
експертів до обміну за турботи всі свої
репутацію письмен шукай давніх вчених ланок
якийсь код високо по саду актив і кіно
підбирав і понад адресу у влади
за провід це поки що раніше закритих у
влади домагалася
різанини та ряди про те та се жадібному
цитокіни вдалося